we are right now embroiled in a scandal
that has rocked the world of progressive
independent media and without rehashing
the entire thing what was once at best a
cordial working relationship between the
David Pakman show and the majority
report would Sam cedar has now reached a
precipice where it made evolved into
lawsuits and possibly even meme Wars as
soon as this weekend and what's at issue
here is the use of the same three panel
room divider that IKEA sells for a
hundred and fifty bucks and has made
available in more than 150 countries for
more than a decade of which there are
millions across people's homes and
offices all over the world because Sam
cedar also uses the same room divider
and he told me exactly where to buy it
exactly how to set it up in any case
there's a provocateur who goes by the
name dron old Raygun who claims to be an
immigration attorney
where's his law degree from I don't know
did he pass the bar on his first try I
couldn't tell you I'm just asking
questions here and this provocateur has
been raising hell on the majority report
and is also trying to raise hell on our
show so what we thought we would do is
let's just go to the audience let's do a
poll on our YouTube community section of
our YouTube channel to see what people
think should happen as a result of this
controversy and the results are truly
truly stunning which I'm going to put up
on the screen for you right now
26% of the respondents want me to quit
YouTube altogether in shame as a result
of this fiasco interestingly only 6% of
the audience in total want either Sam or
I to change our respective sets three
percent say Sam should change his set
that's interesting I'd like to talk to
that three percent three percent say
David needs to change his set twenty
seven percent never want this mentioned
again at all and those are particularly
loud people in my Twitter mentions and
then a plurality forty percent want
progressive voice known in some circles
as the progressive TMZ to mediate some
kind of compromise
that is absolutely incredible as a
result and I would potentially be
willing to let the progressive voice
mediate some kind of settlement here as
long as he was willing to do it on video
because sometimes progressive voice sort
of hides behind images and I'm not gonna
do that he would have to actually be
willing to participate on video and I'd
let him mediate the entire thing by the
way and again I just want to raise this
as a question I'm not saying anything
definitive
has Sam seen Rachel Maddow's set and
compared and contrasted it to what his
looks like just sort of asking questions
here I don't know will this ever die I
hope not because it's very funny